[Bienvenue à l'Espace des Sciences dans cette salle Curien,]
pour partager une nouvelle conférence ce soir.
Pour les habitués, je remplace encore ce soir Maëtte Chantrel et vous la retrouverez la semaine prochaine
Au terme d'un déplacement à l'étranger, elle sera présente la semaine prochaine à 20:30.
Ce soir nous sommes en compagnie d'Olivier Grasset, bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Vous êtes géophysicien, directeur adjoint du laboratoire de planétologie de l'Université de Nantes.
A travers la thématique de cette soirée,
vous allez nous emmener à la recherche des océans extraterrestres.
On va faire un peu plus connaissance dans quelques instants.
Auparavant, et comme c'est notre habitude, ici, à l'Espace des Sciences,
je vais vous présenter quelques ouvrages qui ont été sélectionnés
par l'équipe de bibliothécaires du 3ème étage
pour aller plus loin dans la recherche, la découverte et l'apprentissage
autour du thème de ce soir.
Tout à l'heure je feuilletais cet ouvrage, je sais que vous connaissez bien l'auteur, Olivier Grasset,
elle s'appelle Thérèse Encrenaz.
- Tout à fait, oui, bien sûr (sourires)
[- J'ai bon. L'ouvrage s'appelle "A la recherche de l'eau dans l'univers"]
[Je disais que c'est un ouvrage...] qui avait... la bonne idée
de vulgariser un sujet très complexe et elle le fait avec brio dans cet ouvrage.
[- Oui quand je suis entré dans] la salle tout à l'heure,
vous étiez en train de le regarder. J'ai dit "vous avez pris le bon" (sourires).
Pour faire simple, s'il y en a un, qui décrit de façon exhaustive et simple,
la façon dont on peut explorer et comprendre où est l'eau dans le système solaire et au-delà,
c'est celui-là.
- C'est un ouvrage qui n'est pas très vieux ?
- Vous me posez une colle, je ne me rappelle plus l'année exacte.    - On l'a regardé ensemble (rires)
- Il n'est pas vieux et il est à jour au niveau de ces découvertes.
- C'est un ouvrage paru chez Belin dans la collection "Pour la Science"
que vous trouverez au 3ème étage de la bibliothèque.
Autre ouvrage de Charles Frankel, "Dernières nouvelles des planètes".
Il est géologue, spécialiste du système solaire, comme Thérèse Encrenaz.
Il livre un récit enthousiaste pour saisir les subtilités de mondes
qui se trouvent à des milliards de km de distance,
Ce sera là encore l'objet de votre conférence dans un instant,
même si elle sera plus aqueuse, vous en parlerez.
Dans le domaine de l'eau, cet ouvrage de Jean-Pierre Bibring, préfacé par Hubert Reeves, qu'on ne présente plus.
L'ouvrage s'appelle "Mars, Planète Bleue ?". Vous connaissez l'auteur ?
[- Très bien, oui.]
- Vous validez, vous tamponnez ?
- Oui, aucun problème (sourires), vous pouvez "Mars, Planète bleue ?".
- Rappelons que J-P Bibring est astrophysicien,
responsable de programmes d'exploration spatiale de Mars et des comètes.
Et l'auteur se demande si celle que l'on nomme la planète rouge
n'a pas abrité dans le passé une certaine forme de vie et l'eau en serait le témoignage.
C'est une petite phrase pour résumer un ouvrage qui en dit plus long sur ce thème.
- Je confirme, mais c'est bien dit et...
J'en toucherai mot sur un transparent, pour rappeler la problématique martienne.
Et pourquoi je ne vais pas en parler. On va rester dans le présent et il s'agit là du passé.
Mais on pourra y revenir dans les questions s'il y a des intéressés.
- J'espère. Il y aura des questions à l'issue de cette conférence.
Voilà en tout cas une sélection de 3 ouvrages
que vous pourrez consulter dès demain, si vous avez envie d'aller plus loin
dans cette quête autour des océans extraterrestres.
Vous êtes géophysicien, directeur adjoint du laboratoire de planétologie de l'université de Nantes,
vous dirigez le volet scientifique du projet européen de mission vers Jupiter.
C'est un programme qui est mené conjointement avec la NASA,
On a le sentiment que sans la NASA, on ne pourrait pas faire grand chose.
- Ce n'est pas vrai (rires), non. Par contre, sur ces programmes d'exploration lointaine,
qui sont Jupiter, Saturne et ces mondes là, ceux dont on va parler tout à l'heure,
il est devenu quasiment impossible qu'une agence seule travaille et
mette de bout en bout un projet comme celui là.
Ce n'est pas vrai dans le sens où c'est la même chose pour la NASA.
La NASA n'a plus la prétention de le dire, bien qu'elle l'ait fait dans le passé...
Elle ne peut plus envoyer une mission plus ambitieuse que Galiléo ou Voyager
vers le système lointain sans une contribution forte d'une autre agence.
C'est le cas de Cassini-Huygens par exemple.
- En tout cas, c'est un projet qui vous amène à beaucoup voyager.
Vous avez aussi voyagé pendant vos études, vous avez commencé à Lyon ?
- C'est vrai, oui oui.
- (sourire) Vous avez fait maths sup bio et avez commencé à travailler autour de la géologie.
Vous êtes ingénieur géologue de formation, et vous tenez à ce côté ingénierie.
Là, vous travaillez sur le domaine extra-terrestre,
sur des planètes qui sont à des milliards de km de nous.
Au départ vous partiez sur une formation plus terre à terre, sans mauvais jeu de mot,
vous vous destiniez vers une profession autour des ponts et chaussées.
- C'est vrai, oui, ponts et chaussées, ingénierie.
J'avais le choix entre les pétroles, dans les années 90.
Les gros recrutements des écoles d'ingénieur étaient sur les pétroliers.
Les carrières disparaissaient, il y avait beaucoup de géotechnique.
Ce n'est pas les ponts et chaussées, mais c'est une partie appliquée...
[- Et ensuite vos études ?]
- Ca j'y tiens pas pas trop. Par contre, le terme géologue, j'y tiens.
- Oui.
- Ma formation est une formation de géologue.
Souvent on nous voit comme des astronomes.
Bien entendu je n'ai absolument rien contre les astronomes,
mais le laboratoire de planétologie de Nantes est un composé de géologues.
C'est ce qu'on va voir. La géologie est une discipline de la planétologie.
C'est un peu la spécificité Nantaise.
- J'allais vous demander comment vous êtes passé de Lyon à Nantes.
A travers un projet et des missions qui vous intéressaient,
qui vous ont amené dans les Pays de la Loire.
- Oui, c'est un hasard si je me suis retrouvé à Nantes au début.
Quand mon directeur... Quand j'ai débuté ma thèse,
je ne voulais pas faire ingénieur géologue mais partir dans la planétologie.
J'ai débuté ma thèse sur Orsay et mon directeur,
au bout d'un an, avait cette possibilité de repartir sur Nantes.
En thèse, on peut être plus ou moins proche de son directeur de thèse.
On n'a pas nécessité d'être dans le bureau d'à côté.
Il m'a laissé le choix de rester sur Paris, que je ne connaissais pas du tout,
ou venir avec lui sur Nantes, que je connaissais encore moins,
et j'ai dit 'je viens à Nantes' pour finir la thèse, après je suis reparti et revenu.
- Vous êtes reparti notamment outre Atlantique,
j'imagine quand on travaille sur un domaine tel que le vôtre...
Vous allez me dire 'les américains ne sont pas forcément proéminents (sourire)
et ce n'est pas un passage obligé',
mais vous partez quand même, pendant 18 mois du côté de Boston, travailler sur une mission
qui a fait bouger des choses dans votre carrière, qui a été intéressante ?
- C'est vrai que dans le domaine de la planétologie, tous les européens ont quand même...
Pas un intérêt ; mais c'est toujours gratifiant et intéressant
d'aller voir ce qui se passe outre-Atlantique.
Aprs une thèse, il est naturel de partir un an ou deux à l'étranger.
Pour un européen, plutôt Etats-Unis mais le Japon est un endroit intéressant à explorer.
Pour une durée limitée, après on essaie de revenir.
C'est gratifiant de voir comment ils travaillent, c'est sûr.
- Alors, une question, avant de vous laisser regagner le pupitre et de vous entendre sur le thème de ce soir.
On a bien compris que votre cursus n'est pas porté vers l'astronomie,
mais quand on se lance dans l'astronomie, il n'y a pas...
Quelque part, caché dans l'enfant ou l'adolescent que vous étiez,
une demande de connaissances, une curiosité pour l'astronomie ?
Ou ça vous est venu sur le tard ?
- Je n'ai pas voulu le devenir tout petit,
je ne m'étais pas fixé comme objectif d'être chercheur en planétologie
et de travailler à la préparation de missions spatiales.
[- Vous n'aviez pas écit au dessus de votre lit "un petit pas pour l'Homme, un grand pas pour l'Humanité"]
- Non, non.
- Vous n'aviez pas des étoiles partout sur votre mur ?
- Je ne cache pas que j'ai toujours aimé ça et les sciences en général.
Les planètes et les étoiles m'ont toujours beaucoup plu.
J'avais mis ça de côté durant mon adolescence et une partie de mes études.
Et c'est dans ma grande remise en question, qu'on a tous à un moment donné,
à 18 19 20 21... Quand on se demande ce qu'on va devenir.
J'ai dit finalement 'pourquoi ne pas revenir là-dedans ?'
Mais... J'ai toujours aimé ça, oui.
Je ne pensais pas en faire mon métier. Je ne regrette pas.
- On est ravis. C'est ce qui nous donne l'opportunité de vous entendre...
Oui ? Vous levez la main ?
[...]
- Je vous en prie.
- Vous ne nous entendez pas très bien, d'accord.
On a bientôt terminé pour cette petite conversation.
On va laisser Olivier Grasset rejoindre le pupitre.
Ca va vous prendre 25 secondes. Pour aller sur Mars il faut 3 ans aller-retour ?
- Il faut un an pour y aller. On doit attendre un an parce qu'il faut retomber dans la bonne configuration.
Puis il faut à nouveau un an pour revenir, un peu moins mais globalement. Sur un aller-retour, il faudrait 3 ans.
Mais on ne sait pas faire le retour pour l'instant.
- Ce qui est embêtant.
- C'est mieux là ? (sourire)   - Est ce que c'est mieux ?
Je vous invite à regagner le pupitre. On se retrouvera au terme de votre conférence
pour partager avec vous et vous entendre sur les questions que vous pourrez avoir.
Si d'aventure le son d'O. Grasset n'était pas assez fort,
n'hésitez pas à nous le faire savoir. Bonne conférence.
[bruits de pas, micro allumé qui roule et tombe]
- On l'a bien entendu... [bruits de pas]
- Faut que ça redémarre.
[éclaircissements de gorge... bruits de pas s'éloignant...]
Eh bien c'est parti.
Partons à la recherche des océans extraterrestres.
Je vais essayer ce soir de vous expliquer
pourquoi une partie de la communauté scientifique du domaine spatial
est convaincue qu'il existe dans le système externe,
autour des lunes de Jupiter et de Saturne,
des océans d'eau liquide
aussi denses et probablement beaucoup plus grands
que les océans terrestres que l'on connaît.
Et pour cela, j'ai décidé de faire, si vous êtes d'accord...
En fait, je ne vous laisse pas le choix pour l'instant.
On va d'abord faire un petit rappel.
Où se trouve l'eau dans le système solaire ? Pourquoi, sous quelle forme ?
Pourquoi la majorité de l'eau se trouve dans le système externe.
Une fois qu'on aura compris ça,
on ira faire un tour du côté des lunes de Jupiter et Saturne
et on s'intéressera à la raison pour laquelle on est persuadé qu'il y a des couches liquides en profondeur.
Je vais souvent parler de mers, d'océans, de couches liquides. Dans mon jargon, c'est la même chose.
N'allez pas croire qu'il y a des mers différentes d'océans et que la couche liquide n'est pas la même chose.
On va parler des gros réservoirs liquides à l'intérieur des lunes.
Et dans un dernier temps, suivant le temps qui nous reste,
On discutera plus en détails de ce qu'on verra à partir de 2020. En 2028, 2030 et au delà.
Ca peut paraître loin, mais c'est aujourd'hui qu'on le prépare.
J'aime bien repartir du départ, le système solaire. Où en est-on aujourd'hui de notre compréhension du système solaire ?
Il existe un système interne constitué de planètes telluriques,
c'est à dire, en partant du Soleil : Mercure, Vénus, la Terre et Mars.
Il existe un système externe constitué des planètes géantes avec leur cortège de lunes et d'anneaux
Je rappelle que Jupiter a plus de 55 lunes à ce jour.
Pour Saturne, c'est du même genre.
Pour Uranus et Neptune, pas autant. Mais comme on n'est pas allé voir de près, on ne sait pas exactement combien il peut y en avoir.
Dans la meilleure configuration, on est à quelques dizaines de millions de km, entre la Terre et Mars.
Il faut une petite année pour nous y rendre.
Vers le système externe, la plus proche est Jupiter. C'est entre 650 millions et 1 milliard de km.
C'est un voyage de 6 à 7 ans en routine pour arriver sur le système de Jupiter.
Quand on va vers Saturne, c'est 8 ans de voyage.
Avec la bagatelle de 1.5 milliard de km de distance.
Les mondes dont je vais vous parler ce soir sont là.
On va explorer ensemble les lunes de ce monstre qu'est Jupiter. Rayon 70.000 km a peu près.
Dix fois le rayon de la Terre soit mille fois son volume.
Saturne, plus petite, avec ses lunes.
C'est là qu'on va aller. 5 à 6 ans de voyage minimum.
Les océans extra-terrestres dont on va parler de soir sont dans ce domaine là.
Je ne peux pas esquiver ce qui s'est passé sur cette petite planète rouge qui est Mars.
Je vais en parler rapidement dans cette première partie mais pas par la suite.
S'il y a eu un océan sur Mars, et il y en a sans doute eu un, c'est un océan passé.
Ca n'est pas un océan présent. Les couches liquides existaient dans conditions de Mars il y a 3 milliards d'années.
Les océans du système externe, on pense qu'ils existent aujourd'hui.
Je suis thermodynamicien,
Vous m'excuserez, par deux fois, je vais vous sortir un diagramme de phase.
Celui de l'eau, dont on va parler.
Il faut connaître les bases fondamentales qui font que l'eau est unique et
qui font que l'on va découvrir des océans dans les lunes de Jupiter et Saturne.
C'est très simple : la pression versus la température.
Vous voyez trois choses :
l'eau peut exister sous trois phases, on le sait tous.
Une phase solide, la glace. En ce moment, il y en a pas mal dehors.
L'eau liquide, on la connaît très bien.
Et l'eau gazeuse, on la connaît moins.
Elle est abondante dans les nuées du volcanisme Terrien.
C'est classique, on connaît bien, sur Terre, l'eau sous forme de gaz.
Sans problème, vous connaissez bien ça parce que vous êtes sur Terre.
Et c'est la vraie unicité de la Terre dans le système solaire,
elle possède à sa surface les trois phases de l'eau : la glace, l'eau liquide et l'eau gazeuse.
Il n'y a aucun autre endroit dans le système solaire où on a, à la surface d'un corps, lune ou planète,
cette coexistence des trois phases solide, liquide et gazeuse.
Cette unicité de la Terre, si nous la perdons, nous perdons l'habitabilité et la vie.
C'est ce qui rend la Terre intéressante en planétologie.
Un des problèmes qu'on se pose souvent, c'est pourquoi elle est à cet endroit là ?
Sur une durée aussi longue ? On ne retrouve ça nulle part ailleurs.
La raison est très simple :
A la surface de la Terre, 1 bar de pression.
La température terrestre, quelque part entre -30 et 20 degrés Celsius
Le 1 bar c'est ce 101.3245, je m'excuse pour l'unité en kiloPascal.
Mais c'est le 1 bar de la pression terrestre atmosphère.
La terre est là dedans, sa surface est à proximité du point triple de l'eau.
Ce point ou coexistent les trois phases.
Encore une fois, à aucun autre endroit dans le système solaire vous ne trouverez une planète dont la surface a un environnement proche de ce point triple
avec cette capacité d'aller sur les trois différentes phase de l'eau.
Quand vous reagrdez le système solaire,
sa température diminue très rapidement, c'est la courbe rouge, avec la distance au Soleil.
Ca veut dire que sur la première unité astronomique...
1 UA (unité astronomique) = 150 millions de km.
Sur les 150 premiers millions de km, la distance Terre-Soleil,
vous avez déjà perdu plus de 300 degrés Kelvin.
300 Kelvin, c'est la température ambiante sur Terre.
Après c'est linéaire. On est à environ 100 degré... Pardon... 270... Là on est à 130 degré, ici 230, 330, on est de plus en plus chaud.
Ca descend très vite et, au delà de Mars,
oubliez la notion d'eau liquide parce qu'au delà de Mars,
votre température à la surface des planètes est très en dessous de la température de solidification de l'eau.
Au delà de Mars, toute eau, dans le système solaire, est de la glace, à priori.
A la surface des corps, autour de Saturne, vous voyez, on est à 150 Kelvin, soit -120°C.
Autour de Saturne, on est à moins 180°C,
ici, on avoisine les -230, et ici ce sont les froids intenses à quelques dizaines de Kelvin.
C'est à dire -230°C
Donc oublions tout de suite la notion d'eau liquide à la surface d'une planète.
Excepté dans cet environnement très étroit du système solaire, compris entre la Terre et Mars.
Avec cette notion, naturellement, on définit une zone habitable.
On conçoit tous que l'eau liquide est nécessaire pour la vie.
L'habitabilité, qui n'est pas la vie, mais les conditions nécessaires pour qu'il y ait de la vie sur une planète,
passe d'abord et avant tout par une zone où je peux avoir de l'eau liquide en surface.
Sur une planète qui gravite autour d'une étoile comme le Soleil. Ici l'étoile jaune.
Cette zone habitable est dans un domaine très réduit
où la température permet d'avoir cette eau liquide en surface.
Au delà, il fait trop froid, tout est gelé.
Avant, c'est trop chaud, tout est gazeux
Cette notion de zone habitable évolue.
Parmi les autres systèmes planétaires, aujourd'hui plus de 500 exoplanètes découvertes autour d'autres étoiles.
On pourra en parler après.
Autour d'autres étoiles, la zone habitable doit exister mais
elle va être distincte de celle du Soleil
car l'étoile brille moins et est fond plus froide.
Ou brille plus, et est donc plus chaude.
La notion d'eau liquide se cantonne toujours à un espace très restreint dans l'environnement stellaire
parce qu'à la surface, il y a peu d'endroits où je peux avoir de l'eau liquide.
Cette image est un montage car il n'y pas de nuages.
Le cas terrestre est unique car il donne l'impression d'eau partout.
Si vous cherchez de l'eau dans le système solaire, ne la cherchez pas dans le système interne,
dans les planètes telluriques.
Toute l'eau disponible représente 0.01% du poids total de la Terre.
C'est à dire rien.
Ça nous parait impressionnant car ça couvre une surface immense et c'est unique.
Ce n'est pas impressionnant dans le sens où c'est beaucoup d'eau.
4500m en moyenne, les océans terrestres,
ramenés aux 6400km du rayon de la Terre,
qui sont avant tout des silicates et du fer, surtout de silicates.
La Terre est une boule d'oxygène, à laquelle j'ajoute du magnésium, du fer et de la silice.
Mais ce n'est pas une planète d'eau.
Le pourcentage d'eau est très faible. Les océans sont là mais
l'eau du système solaire n'est pas sur Terre.
Vénus et Mercure, c'est encore pire, car c'est dans un environnement plus chaud.
Toute l'eau qu'il y avait s'est beaucoup évaporée dès les stades primordiaux.
Ce sont des planètes très sèches.
Pendant longtemps, avant les missions spatiales,
on a pensé que Vénus était un peu la jumelle de la Terre, à juste titre.
Même taille, une atmosphère, environnement similaire, à peu près la même distance à l'étoile.
Un peu trop près de son étoile, elle a perdu son eau dans l'atmosphère,
dans les océans s'il y en avait. Aussi dans les silicates, ce sont des roches très sèches.
C'est une des raisons qui explique l'absence de tectonique des plaques sur Vénus.
Et pourquoi la Terre a une tectonique des plaques. C'est cette possibilité d'avoir gardé de l'eau dans les silicates.
Vénus est pire mais je dirais 'même combat', il y a très peu d'eau dans ces planètes telluriques.
Mars est à part.
Vous avez vu des images de Mars, comme celle en haut à gauche,
ce paysage martien très stérile, très austère.
Sans une goutte d'eau, ce caillou rouge, cette masse d'oxydes un peu partout.
Avec les dernières missions comme Mars Express, Mars Global Surveyor,
des orbiteurs ont fait de l'imagerie très haute résolution de la surface de Mars,
on a pu mettre en évidence des structures.
Cette image 3D n'est pas une fausse image.
Mars Express a une caméra qui peut viser avec deux angles différents
et reproduire presque en direct une image stéréo.
C'est une vraie image très haute résolution de la surface de Mars.
On en a beaucoup comme ça qui montrent que...
A un moment donné, il y a certainement eu des écoulements en surface.
On voit partout des figures d'érosion qui laissent penser qu'il y a eu sûrement de l'eau liquide sur Mars.
Vous avez peut être eu, ici, une conférence sur Mars ?
On peut discuter 1h30 sur les images martiennes,
de la forte probabilité d'avoir eu de l'eau liquide à la surface de Mars.
Le problème de Mars est clair.
Dans mon fameux diagramme de phase,
la Terre est par là. Mars était là, on en est quasiment persuadés.
Elle était un peu trop petite et un peu trop loin de son étoile.
On est quasiment sûr qu'elle a perdu son atmosphère
et que sa surface a migré vers une très basse pression et une basse température.
Ma flèche devrait continuer. Elle a migré dans un domaine où l'eau liquide n'existe plus.
En dessous du point triple, vous ne pouvez plus avoir d'eau liquide.
Avec une allumette, vous pouvez transformer votre glace en gaz, c'est la sublimation,
mais transformer la glace en eau liquide est impossible.
Parce que la pression actuelle à la surface de Mars est en dessous du point critique.
Vous ne pouvez plus avoir d'eau liquide.
C'est le cas standard dans le système solaire.
La pression dans les comètes, dans l'espace est très basse.
Nous sommes toujours en dessous du point critique.
Ainsi les comètes qui se subliment en approchant du Soleil transforment leur glace en gaz.
La queue cométaire est faite d'eau gazeuse, d'accord ?
Et pas du tout liquide. C'est parce qu'on est en dessous de ce point noir.
Mars est dans ce cas là.
Je ne sais pas si Mars a eu ce type d'océans. D'aucuns le croient.
Il y a un débat dans la communauté scientifique sur l'existence ou non d'eau liquide à la surface de Mars.
Globalement, tout le monde est d'accord.
Il y a aussi débat sur l'existence ou non d'océans à la surface de Mars.
Je ne suis pas spécialiste, je ne peux pas dire qui a tort ou raison.
Le débat est ouvert, on manque de données.
C'est sûr que l'eau était là.
A t elle généré ou non des océans, on ne sait pas.
C'était il y a 3 milliards d'années et depuis, on est passé sous le point critique.
Si vous voulez de l'eau, elle est là,
dans ce domaine là où, depuis le début, il fait très froid
et l'eau est sous forme de glace.
Elle n'a pas pu disparaître, la glace primordiale, qu'on avait au début du système solaire.
Il fait tellement froid que, mélangée aux roches, elle n'a pas disparu. Elle doit toujours être là.
La question est : dans quelles proportions ?
Avec l'avènement des missions spatiales, les deux Voyager,
envoyées dans les années 70
et qui ont envoyé des données dans les années 80,
Galiléo autour de Jupiter,
et enfin la mission Cassini,
on a de plus en plus d'évidences que la surface des lunes qui entourent les planètes géantes,
est principalement constituée d'eau.
On le savait longtemps avant, avec l'astronomie au sol.
Ce qu'on appelle l'albédo, cette intensité de réflexion des surfaces planétaires.
Avec un albédo semblable à celui de la neige,
on pouvait dire que les lunes de Jupiter et Saturne étaient vraisemblablement des corps glacés.
Ceci étant, la preuve nécessitait des observations à plus haute résolution,
pour avoir plus de détails, c'est chose faite.
Maintenant on va parler de ces lunes, autour de Jupiter et autour de Saturne.
Je vais vous les présenter pour qu'on parle tous de la même chose.
La tâche rouge de Jupiter a un diamètre semblable à celui de la Terre,
pour resituer les choses à leur place.
A peu près à l'échelle, vous avez les quatre stars du système Jovien.
Io, dont je ne parlerai plus car ce n'est pas un satellite de glace, c'est l'exception qui confirme la règle.
Pourquoi ce n'en est pas un ? C'est facile à expliquer.
C'est une planète dont la surface est constituée de soufre.
Pardon c'est une lune
qui a une surface soufrée.
Il n'y a pas de glace ici. C'est un corps très actif et célèbre pour son volcanisme actuel dynamique,
ce qui n'est pas le cas de beaucoup de corps dans le système solaire.
Europe, une star, on va beaucoup en parler.
C'est une lune de 1575 km de rayon qui a une surface glacée.
Ganymède et Callisto, deux autres grosses lunes.
Ganymède est un peu plus grosse que notre Lune. Surface glacée, on y reviendra.
Callisto, une surface qui ne paraît pas glacée, mais qui l'est.
Sa surface est très vielle, cratérisée et elle a beaucoup de poussières à sa surface.
Sous la poussière, vous avez de la glace.
Autour de Saturne, la grande star c'est Titan. On y reviendra.
Titan est de la taille de Ganymède, c'est une très grosse lune.
Les autres sont des petites lunes, on parlera d'Encelade, parce qu'elle est active,
avec un volcanisme présent d'eau.
Je présenterai rapidement les autres mais je me concentrerai sur les grosses lunes :
Europe, Ganymède, Callisto, Titan et un peu Encelade.
On peut vous démontrer sans difficulté qu'elles sont constituées principalement de glace.
Lorsque vous regardez Encelade, petite lune de Saturne, avec un spectromètre infrarouge...
Dans le spectre électromagnétique, on balaye toutes les ondes
depuis les rayonnements ultra durs jusqu'aux ondes centimétriques.
Le domaine du visible est très réduit.
Pour déterminer des compositions de planètes, vous allez utiliser l'ultraviolet et l'infrarouge, en planétologie.
Vous voyez ici la longueur d'onde,
Dans le domaine du proche infrarouge, depuis 1 micron jusque 5 microns...
Pour rappel, le domaine visible est à gauche.
Ce diagramme est une mesure de l'intensité lumineuse pour les différentes longueurs d'onde.
Vous prenez une image en couleurs et pour l'étendre dans le domaine visible,
ce diagramme vous dit combien il a de vert, de bleu, de rouge dans cette image couleurs.
Combien de jaune, combien de ceci cela. Ce n'est que ça.
Ici, on le fait dans le domaine infrarouge, un peu au delà du visible.
Avec une caméra hyper spectrale, en plus de l'image, on a la dimension spectrale,
on mesure le nombre de photons qui passent sur une fenêtre réduite de longueurs d'onde.
Ce qui va faire un spectre.
Ce spectre là, en rouge, celui des anneaux de Saturne, que vous voyez en bleu sur l'image,
et qui est en noir celui de la surface d'Encelade, cette grosse lune,
est rigoureusement et exactement le même que celui que je ferais en laboratoire avec un cristal de glace sorti du frigo
et sur lequel je vais plaquer mon spectromètre infrarouge, selon la précision de l’appareil de mesure.
C'est quasiment de la glace ultra pure que vous pourriez produire dans votre frigo ou ramasser dehors en ce moment.
C'est la même parce que cette signature, cette intensité lumineuse par unité de longueur d'onde, est caractéristique de la glace d'eau.
Donc oui, on peut affirmer que Encelade a de la glace quasi pure sur toute sa surface.
Encelade a cette particularité d'avoir des geysers.
La mission Cassini est passée à l'intérieur de ces geysers et a pu mesurer, avec un spectromètre de masse,
cette abondance en eau, preuve indépendante de la richesse en eau de cette lune.
Parmi les autres, Hypérion ou Japet avec sa montagne équatoriale,
un bourrelet équatorial un peu bizarre sur cette petite lune.
Ou sur Dione, qui a une géologie particulière, pareil.
Toutes ces petites lunes sont avant tout constituées de glace.
Les grosses lunes, on sait par la spectroscopie et l'imagerie, l'albédo est là pour le dire, que la surface est glace.
On a aussi des informations importantes sur leurs tailles, leurs rayons et donc leurs densités, ou masses volumiques moyennes.
Cette densité est en fait pile au milieu entre l'eau et le caillou.
Autrement dit, la masse et le rayon de ces corps ne s'expliquent que si on a la moitié de la masse comme des silicates
et l'autre moitié comme des glaces.
Ca a une petite implication.
Quand ce truc là fait 2400 km de rayon, que la moitié de sa masse est de la glace,
ça veut dire que la couche de glace s'étend sur 800 km d'épaisseur.
On est loin des 4000m de l'océan terrestre.
Quand je regarde Titan, Ganymède et Callisto, que je parle de lunes gelées,
on pense que les couches solides de glace ont une épaisseur de 600 à 800 km.
Donc oui. L'eau est là.
Europe est à part, on y reviendra.
C'était le préambule.
On a vu où se trouve l'eau dans le système solaire et pourquoi.
On a va se concentrer sur les lunes, car c'est là qu'est l'eau
et on va voir pourquoi, sous cette glace...
On se rappelle que la température de Jupiter est de -120°C,
Saturne, -180°.
On a notre diagramme de phase en tête, on a du mal à imaginer de l'eau liquide,
alors que je vous dis que c'est gelé.
La base du problème est le diagramme de phase.
L'eau est unique, la Terre est unique.
En fait, il y a 3 éléments qui ont cette particularité
d'avoir une pente de Clapeyron négative.
Personne n'est choqué de voir cette courbe
qui donne la limite entre les domaines solide et liquide de l'eau.
C'est une courbe qui voit la pression augmenter quand la pression diminue.
Vous avez raison de ne pas être choqué. Pourquoi pas ?
La grande majorité des éléments connus et globalement tous les matériaux,
ont une pente qui va plutôt dans ce sens là.
Exceptés le mercure et l'eau, les autres ont une pente de Clapeyron positive.
La  température de fusion, passage du solide au liquide,
augmente naturellement quand la pression augmente.
Pas l'eau. Vous allez me dire que ce n'est pas grave, certes.
Pourtant sur Terre, vous connaissez cela,
qui est intéressant et important.
Cette propriété de l'eau nous permet d'envisager, sur Terre,
dans des environnements très froids,
la présence d'eau liquide en profondeur.
Vous avez entendu parler du Lac Vostok
et de la centaine de lacs qui existent sous la calotte antarctique.
En imagerie radar aéroportée,
ici la calotte antarctique avec tout un tas de reliefs,
c'est cabossé dans tous les sens, excepté sur certaines zones.
Ici la surface du lac Ontario, 50 km de long sur 20 km de large.
Cela correspond une zone très plane difficile à expliquer.
Sauf quand on a l'explication.
Cette zone là, très connue, est celle du lac Vostok sur laquelle
il y a une base russe depuis 30ans.
L'environnement Vostok, c'est pas Rennes dans les temps les plus froids.
-50° de moyenne, la canicule c'est -12, c'est arrivé une fois,
la température estivale est plutôt -à 32 et la plus basse est à -82.
On est sur Terre.
Ce n'est pas le milieu extraterrestre, mais c'est très hostile.
Pas question d'envisager l'eau liquide en surface.
Mais descendons.
Les Russes ont fait un forage, comme il y en a beaucoup en Antarctique.
Ces forages ont plusieurs objectifs, dont un scientifique.
C'est une bonne façon de retracer l'histoire de l'atmosphère terrestre
et son évolution sur les derniers millénaires.
Dans ce carottage des glaces antarctiques, quand on descend dans les strates,
on avance dans le passé.
Depuis qu'on se doute, par imagerie radar,
qu'il y a un océan en profondeur,
on a creusé pour arriver à l'eau liquide.
Mais pourquoi cette eau liquide ?
Parce que, quand vous descendez dans le trou...
La pression est la masse de ce qu'il y a au dessus,
donc plus vous descendez, plus la pression augmente.
Je m'excuse, le diagramme est dans le mauvais sens afin de lire les axes.
A Vostok, -50, on est très bas,
mais sous la surface, on atteint vite -5, -10.
On est par là, à 1 bar, au point rouge, à la surface de Vostok.
Quand je descends dans le trou et que la  pression augmente,
j'envisage de croiser cette courbe de liquéfaction.
C'est la propriété de l'eau à se transformer en liquide.
Je descends juste dans le trou, la pression augmente à température constante,
la thermodynamique m'impose, et j'y crois,  d'avoir de l'eau liquide en profondeur.
Imparable, c'est une preuve indiscutable.
Il n'y a pas 36 façons d'avoir cette surface ultra plane dans ce contexte, il faut du liquide en profondeur.
Depuis, plusieurs explorations à radar bistatique ont démontré la présence d'eau liquide.
Le lac Ontario est bien là, à quelques km de profondeur,
pour une raison physique très simple, cette pente de Clapeyron négative.
Mais quel rapport avec nos lunes gelées ?
On a des missions, comme Galiléo,
qui sont allées vers Jupiter.
La mission Cassini-Huygens, vers Saturne et Titan.
Elles nous ont ramené beaucoup de données qui nous font penser que
cette propriété thermodynamique de l'eau, qui permet l'eau liquide en profondeur sur Terre,
s'applique aux lunes riches en eau du système externe solaire.
Les évidences sont là.
Prenons Europe, cette petite lune de Jupiter. 1500 km de rayon.
Elle est particulière car elle a moins d'eau que les autres qui ont 600km d'eau.
Et ensuite les roches. Europe est plus petite,
elle a moins d'eau, pour les mêmes raisons que Io, on pourra en parler à la fin.
Europe a moins d'eau que Ganymède et Callisto, environ 100km.
Avant la mission Galiléo, on pensait que cette eau était glacée à cause du froid.
Puis sont arrivées des images de très haute résolution.
Ici, ce n'est pas le lac Vostok, c'est un impact de cratère.
Autour on voit des linéaments, une tectonique complexe, plein de choses
avec des noms différents.
Des grabones effondrement, des failles déformantes, ici.
Ceci démontre une dynamique très intense.
Ce n'est pas la preuve qu'il y a de l'eau en en dessous,  mais s'il y en avait, ça aiderait pas mal.
Une image qui a fait le tour du monde en 1995... Pardon, 1997.
Le "Conemarra chaos", en haute résolution.
On voit une banquise, en haut à gauche.
Elle est morcelée partout.
On devine, en travaillant sur l'image,
que c'est un puzzle, c'est comme une débâcle de banquise.
On peut recoller les morceaux sans problème.
C'est la démonstration du fait que ces blocs ont subi
une migration de la gauche vers la droite et du haut vers le bas,
dans un contexte de débâcle de banquise.
Ce que l'on voit en grumeleux gris, ici, ne correspond pas à de l'eau liquide.
Peut-être l'eau liquide est en dessous.
On a peut-être eu un fluage, cette glace était plus molle
et a permis ce mouvement indiscutable.
La nature nous a bien aidés dans ce cas car toutes ces lignes
nous permettent de recoller le puzzle facilement.
Sur les autres lunes, c'est similaire.
Ganymède, c'est moins flagrant, on voit des structures d'extension,
des choses sont montées vers la surface et
ont écarté les manteaux ou panneaux de glace pour se figer.
On le voit ici en noir, en fausse couleur,
des linéations très abondantes à la surface de Ganymède.
Cela démontre que du matériau est venu du fond et a écarté le reste pour se faire sa place.
On peut l'expliquer sans eau liquide. Ça aide d'en avoir.
Ces images très haute résolution sont en faveur de ces arguments.
Ici une image de Ganymède,
on voit ces zones d'extension avec un matériau plus clair, plus jeune, peu cratérisé,
qui a fait sa place en écartant le reste.
Ce n'est pas une preuve d'eau liquide en dessous mais ça aiderait pour favoriser
ce dynamisme assez intense.
Titan est autour de Saturne,
c'est Cassini-Huygens qui donne ces images.
Elles montrent une dynamique très complexe. Ce n'est pas une preuve d'eau liquide.
On a découvert des lacs de méthane, éthane, éthylène etc...
On est à -200° en surface donc ce n'est pas de l'eau liquide.
Il y a un cycle du méthane sur Titan, une atmosphère,
on voit des dunes, des montagnes, peut-être des volcans, des écoulements,
Si on a le temps, on verra la descente de Huygens sur Saturne.
On a l'impression d'arriver sur la baie de Pornic.
Ces images rasantes donnent une impression extraordinaire.
C'est un monde très dynamique.
Ce n'est pas une preuve de couche liquide en profondeur mais
c'est un argument pour dire que ce n'est pas un monde mort.
Le plus dynamique d'entre eux est Encelade,
avec ses célèbres "tiger stripes", ses griffes de tigre,
qu'on voit sur le pôle sud.
Il est griffé avec 4 grandes failles
espacées de quelques centaines de km les unes des autres.
Pourquoi pas ? C'est original,
surtout les geysers qui sortent de ces griffures,
constitués principalement d'eau liquide.
Un peu d’ammoniaque et quelques sulfates.
On a affaire à un monde étrange, dont le dynamisme est intense et
l'eau liquide sort. De là à dire qu'elle est dessous, il n'y a qu'un pas à franchir,
que beaucoup ont franchi sans hésiter.
Il n'y a pas que les observations géologiques.
Ceux qui adorent la physique vont se rappeler leurs cours.
La règle des trois doigts.
La magnétosphère Jovienne est intense,
c'est un champ magnétique. Celui de la Terre, à côté, c'est de la rigolade.
Cela génère une ceinture de radiations de l'ordre de 4 millions de Rad,
à la surface d'Europe. Vous grillez toute électronique en quelques heures,
sans la bonne carcasse de plomb autour des instruments. C'est du sérieux.
Il y a un très fort champ magnétique autour de Jupiter.
Quand Galiléo s'est approchée de Jupiter,
elle a découvert des champs magnétiques induits :
le magnétomètre, au lieu d'enregistrer le bruit continu de la magnétosphère Jovienne,
a enregistré tout un tas de bruits bizarres.
Ici une chute du champ magnétique associée à quelque chose.
Quand on construit ça en 3D,
on voit que ce quelque chose a cette géométrie là.
Il existe un champ magnétique induit qui perturbe le champ Jovien.
Pour faire un champ induit, il faut la règle des trois doigts.
Avec un champ magnétique, si vous avez un courant conducteur,
vous générez un champ magnétique induit.
On a le champ primaire Jovien, Galiléo a mesuré le champ induit,
donc il y a un courant.
Qu'est ce qui vous fait un courant conducteur,
sinon un océan salé ?
Ça peut être un noyau de fer ou un océan salé.
La ré-analyse des données Galiléo
tend à montrer que l'origine de ce courant conducteur
est superficielle. Ce n'est pas le noyau de fer.
Je n'affirme pas que c'est un océan salé mais
il faut un courant dynamique conducteur en profondeur d'Europe, Ganymède et Callisto.
Les trois ont un champ magnétique induit.
Pour Ganymède, cette image est belle.
Elle a un champ propre, comme la Terre.
On ne l'explique pas mais c'est une preuve de son activité.
C'est lié à son noyau de fer.
C'est un satellite avec une dynamique comme la Terre.
Un champ magnétique, un champ induit, un noyau de fer, des silicates, des glaces sur Ganymède.
On a des évidences géophysiques et géologiques. Il nous manque une dernière,
celle de composition.
Je n'ai pas parlé d'océan salé par hasard.
Cette image a fait le tour du monde dans la presse spécialisée.
C'est une image fausse couleur haute résolution.
Sur l'écran, on a 1000km de la surface d'Europe.
Fausse couleur pour retraduire le spectre infrarouge dont on a parlé.
En bleu, c'est la même chose que la glace d'Encelade ou des anneaux dont on a parlé,
c'est de la glace quasi pure.
En rouge, ce n'est pas de la glace.
On le sait par l'imagerie hyper spectrale.
La caméra infra rouge de Galiléo a démontré que
tout le bleu a un spectre similaire à celui en vert,
celui de la glace de laboratoire.
Le rouge n'a rien à voir.
Beaucoup de papiers scientifiques sont sortis sur le sujet
pour savoir ce qu'était ce rouge.
Ce n'est pas anodin, le rouge est dans les failles, dans les cisaillements, au niveau des cratères d'impact.
Ce qui est moucheté, c'est les éjectats d'un cratère d'impact.
Ce rouge, c'est très probablement des sels,
peut-être des argiles, mais peu y croient.
Probablement des sulfates de magnésium, des sulfates de sodium.
Ce jour, c'est la meilleure façon qu'on a de reproduire le spectre en rouge.
Sur cette image, on voit à peu près la même chose,
du dioxyde de carbone, des sulfates, du magnésium
sur les autres lunes, mais c'est moins flagrant.
Ici, en rouge le CO2 par exemple.
Quand vous cumulez tout ça dans le contexte d'Europe,
ces évidences sur la composition, sur la géologie, avec cette dérive des blocs,
cette évidence forte du champ magnétique induit,
vous avez du mal à ne pas affirmer qu'il y a de l'eau liquide en profondeur.
Il y a 30 ans, on n'imaginait pas l'eau liquide en profondeur.
Aujourd'hui il est difficile de dire qu'il n'y a pas d'eau liquide en profondeur.
Pour autant, on ne l'a pas encore prouvé.
Ici, la surface d'Europe.
100km ici. Ici, l'océan terrestre et la pellicule de surface.
Là, sur 100 km de profondeur. En bas les silicates,
avec une activité sans doute présente.
Le débat est de savoir si c'est comme à gauche ou comme à droite ?
L'océan monte t il près de la surface et la croute de glace ne fait que quelques km d'épaisseur ?
Ou l'océan est il profond ? Ici on voit des diapires, montées de matériau chaud,
mais on n'est pas dans la liquide, on est dans la glace molle.
Un peu comme des silicates terrestres.
En profondeur, les silicates sont plutôt un savon, il ne sont pas cassants.
On est dans la même logique. Ici, c'est très cassant,
mais dès qu'on descend, la température est plus proche de celle de fusion.
On a une glace plus molle.
Est on là ou là ? Je vous en reparle en 2028 si tout va bien.
Il est sûr qu'Europa ressemble à ça.
Quand on fait le bilan, on se rend compte de tout ça.
La température en surface est -120, mais en profondeur proche de 0°.
Peut être des hautes températures, en cas de geysers.
La pression est ultra vide en surface mais, dès que je descends dans mon océan,
ça va beaucoup mieux. Dans l'océan, j'attaque à quelques bars
et au plus bas je suis au maximum à 1000 bar.
1000 bar c'est plus que nocif pour nous.
On connaît les organismes barophiles et hyperbarophiles
qui résistent à 1000 bar.
La composition est sans doute inconnue mais, comme on l'a vu,
ce n'est pas de l'eau distillée.
Il y a sans doute des sels et une chimie complexe, c'est presque certain.
Les radiations sont catastrophiques, on grille tout en surface.
Sous quelques mètres de glace, vous n'avez plus de radiation.
On est protégé en profondeur.
Il n'y a pas de lumière en profondeur.
A 100 km de profondeur, on est dans le noir total, ce n'est pas grave.
Les fumeurs noirs abritent la vie dans les planchers océaniques, on le sait depuis 35 ans,
dans les mêmes conditions que mon tableau de gauche.
Je ne vais jamais vous dire qu'il y a de la vie sur Europe.
Je peux affirmer qu'on pense que les conditions sur Europe
sont peut-être réunies pour avoir un environnement viable.
A notre connaissance, il n'y a pas d'autre endroit
dans le système solaire où on peut affirmer une telle chose.
Reste à prouver que les océans sont là.
On a des évidences mais pas de preuve.
Même si on prouve qu''ils sont là,
on ne sera pas capable d'aller détecter s'il y a des micro-organismes à 100km de profondeur.
On en est très loin, ça reste de la science fiction.
Encore une fois, je ne dis pas qu'ils sont là mais les évidences sont un argument fort
pour justifier les futures missions vers Jupiter.
En particulier Europe.
Les autres lunes sont différentes.
Je laisse tomber ma thermodynamique compliquée mais,
simplement, la pression est un monde étrange.
On se cantonne trop à la pression atmosphérique
qui est à la surface terrestre.
Quand vous pénétrez dans un manteau glacé de 600 ou 800km de profondeur,
on doit admettre que la pression va augmenter assez vite.
Les glaces vont subir des pressions beaucoup plus importantes que 1 bar.
1 gigaPascal, je traduis par 10000 bar.
A l'interface entre silicates et couches de glace,
on est à 10000 fois la pression atmosphérique.
La glace que vous connaissez, celle du frigo, n'existe plus.
Il y a très longtemps qu'elle s'est transformée en glace V, glace II, glace VI, glace III...
Des polymorphes haute pression de la glace,
découverts par Bridgman, prix Nobel en 1914.
Ce n'est pas neuf.
Bridgman avait démontré la complexité du diagramme de phase de l'eau,
pas seulement sa pente de Clapeyron négative,
ces nombreuses phases haute pression dans le contexte de l'eau.
On retrouve ma pente de Clapeyron ici,
la température diminue quand la pression augmente.
En bleu foncé le liquide, en bleu clair la glace.
Cette pente de Clapeyron redevient standard car
la température ré-augmente avec la pression quand je passe vers les glaces haute pression.
Ah oui ?! Quand je descends le long de ma flèche,
je peux passer par un liquide mais je retomberai sur du solide.
Donc Europe est une lune unique parce que les autres
sont appelées par les américains des "sandwich oceans".
Les océans peuvent exister sous 800 km de glace mais
n'imaginez pas 800km d'eau liquide.
L'eau liquide est cantonnée entre deux glaces :
la glace de basse pression, qu'on trouve en surface et sur plusieurs km d'épaisseur,
et, en dessous, cette glace haute pression.
C'est l'élément prépondérant de ces lunes géantes.
Cette particularité rend l’habitabilité plus complexe car
pour avoir les sources d'énergie venant des silicates,
par les geysers et  par cette activité, pour avoir la chimie complexe,
il faut que la chimie et l'énergie se frayent un chemin à travers ces km de glace.
Ce n'est pas impossible mais c'est difficile.
J'y reviens juste après.
Pour conclure là dessus,
est ce qu'il y a des océans partout ? Mises à part les toutes petites lunes...
Ici quelques exemples de lunes, de la plus grande à la plus petite.
Ici les géantes qu'on a vu avant.
Dans un papier qui date de 2005, les allemands (Roc ?) et Usman on dit que,
dans les structures  internes, on a de la glace et de l'eau liquide sur toutes les lunes des planètes géantes.
La question de l'habitabilité est particulière.
Pour rendre un monde habitable, il faut 4 éléments considérables :
la présence d'eau liquide, un environnement stable...
Il faut du temps, Mars en est l'exemple, pour faire durer un monde habitable.
Il faut plus que des milliers d'années, l'évolution ne s'est pas faite comme ça.
Il faut des éléments chimiques complexes, ce n'est pas simple à fournir dans l'environnement liquide.
Et il faut de l'énergie chimique.
Je ne dis pas qu'avec ça, vous faites la vie.
Les exobiologistes et planétologues sont d'accord sur la nécessité
de la pyramide des 4 éléments essentiels,
sans lesquels on ne peut pas définir un monde habitable.
Ce qui ne veut pas dire viable, j'insiste.
La Terre est là. Points verts partout.
Europe a des points verts mais ça reste à prouver.
On pense que ce sont des points verts partout.
Ganymède n'est pas loin. Le problème est de véhiculer l'énergie chimique
qui vient d'en bas, des silicates, à travers cette couche de glace haute pression.
Ce n'est pas trivial, c'est sans doute faisable, on n'a pas de preuve.
On va mettre un point jaune, on reste réservé.
Pour les autres, c'est plus compliqué.
Titan, similaire à Ganymède, a d'autres problèmes. C'est plus loin donc plus dur d'aller voir.
Les autres ont au moins deux points jaunes, peut-être un point rouge.
Encelade est très active, a de l'eau liquide, de l'énergie, tout ce qu'il faut, mais
on explique mal la durée d'un geyser de cette intensité là, sur plusieurs milliard d'années.
On pense que c'est un épisode sur plusieurs millions, peut-être transitoire.
Justifier d'un environnement stable de 4 milliards d'années, qui rendrait Encelade habitable, est très difficile.
Terminons avec les missions.
J'ai fait trois bons quarts d'heure pour vous énumérer où on en est aujourd'hui.
J'espère vous avoir convaincu qu'on peut affirmer qu'il y a des océans dans les lunes des planètes géantes.
Les planètes géantes sont passionnantes. On peut en parler longtemps.
On veut y retourner parce que les lunes sont là et que ce tableau existe.
Mars est une cible privilégiée pour la vie passée.
Les missions que l'on défend, à savoir un retour vers Jupiter, sur lesquelles je travaille,
ont un thème imposé par la NASA et l'Agence Spatiale Européenne,
c'est l'étude de l'émergence des mondes habitables autour des planètes géantes.
Encore une fois, habitables.
C'est une motivation très forte.
Je dois vous parler de l’environnement de Saturne
car le présent c'est la mission Cassini-Huygens.
C'est un succès énorme. Tout ce qu'on a vu vient de cette communauté scientifique
qui a monté cette mission depuis 30 ans et qui va continuer de la faire tourner dans une mission étendue de 7 ans.
Je dois vous montrer ce film, avec un peu de texte en anglais.
Il est très convaincant pour justifier l'importance de ces missions spatiales.
[musique]
[musique, grésillements]
[musique, cris de joie, applaudissements]
It is great, thank you.
[There is strong evidence now...]
[faced upon... radiate energy... microwaves...]
[that the dark areas, and perhaps even most of the surface of Titan,]
is in fact covered with organic material
[musique]
C'est bref, court et convaincant, je trouve [sourire] mais j'ai un parti pris.
Tout ce que j'ai montré, c'est la mission Galiléo, avant.
Maintenant c'est Cassini-Huygens, étendue jusqu'en 2018.
Cassini ne démontrera pas qu'il y a un océan sur Titan car elle n'en a pas les moyens.
Titan est complexe, avec une atmosphère très dense.
Cassini, qui n'a pas d'orbiteur,
fait des survols très rapprochés de la majorité des lunes de Saturne, en particulier.
Elle a montré beaucoup de choses, qu'on balaye en deux minutes, avec des images flash.
Mais elle ne pourra pas faire ça.
Elle nous donnera encore des informations,  j'en suis certain.
Si vous voulez démontrer et avancer sur notre compréhension de l'émergence des mondes habitables,
de cette capacité des lunes à abriter des couches liquides,
il va falloir envoyer au moins des orbiteurs qui tourneront autour des lunes.
Non pas faire des tours dans le système de Saturne ou Jupiter, mais autour des lunes.
Il y a deux missions en compétition.
Une va passer d'abord, la mission vers Jupiter.
Et peut-être plus tard vers Titan.
Cette mission s'apelle EJSM-Laplace. Europa Jupiter System Mission,
un engin spatial qui va orbiter autour d'Europe.
Laplace pour la contribution européenne, un deuxième orbiteur,
autant en envoyer deux d'un coup,
pour explorer l'autre lune, Ganymède.
Je n'ai parlé que des lunes.
Vous pouvez avoir une heure de conférence sur la géologie même des lunes,
une autre sur les atmosphères, car ces lunes en ont des très complexes et ténues.
On a parlé des plasmas et magnétosphères.
Tout est passionnant pour tout le monde
mais le système de Jupiter va être exploré dans son ensemble.
Si vous envoyez un engin là bas, il doit tourner pendant deux ans,
avant de se mettre en orbite autour d'une lune.
On est loin de Star Trek, on ne fait pas ce qu'on vaut.
C'est très difficile de se mettre en orbite autour d'une lune,
alors qu'on doit lutter contre la gravitation de Jupiter ou Saturne.
Elles portent bien leurs noms de planètes géantes.
Éviter les ceintures de radiations, les pièges gravitationnels, les petits corps...
Arriver à bien se positionner nécessite du temps, au moins deux ans,
pendant lesquels on va faire cette science globale du système et des lunes.
Aujourd'hui, comment vendre une mission,
il s'agit de la vendre, c'est une compétition,
qui va démontrer l'existence des océans ?
La physique est simple, c'est presque mon dernier transparent,
c'est la force des marées.
Les orbites des planètes autour du Soleil et des lunes autour de leurs planètes
ne sont pas circulaires mais elliptiques,
avec une excentricité plus  ou moins forte.
Autrement dit l'ellipse est plus ou moins circulaire mais jamais complètement.
Cette ellipticité fait qu'une lune est plus ou moins loin de sa planète, et une planète de son étoile.
La force de gravitation n'est pas toujours la même et votre planète se déforme obligatoirement.
Cette déformation symbolisée par les fléchés rouges et bleues, en haut à gauche,
on va la mesurer. Un orbiteur autour d'une lune,
avec un altimètre laser, on va pouvoir le positionner avec un mètre de précision, tout ça à 1 milliard de km de la Terre.
Ce n'est plus un problème aujourd'hui.
Pas en instantané mais en répétitif.
Dans le film précédent, les orbites de Cassini sont quasiment à ça.
Lors des survols de Titan, le problème pour positionner Cassini
était de mal positionner Titan car
les éphémérides de Titan étaient mal connues.
On avait plus d'incertitudes sur la position de Titan que sur celle du satellite.
On a corrigé bien sûr.
On va donc mettre un orbiteur, positionné très précisément dans l'espace
par rapport à la surface, grâce à un altimètre.
En plus, vous mesurerez, en continu, son orbite circulaire autour de la lune.
L'orbite va se déformer car la planète va se déformer,
dans son cycle autour de Jupiter.
C'est le diagramme en bas à gauche.
On peut traduire ce moment gravitationnel en altitude.
Soit vous avez des océans et une déformation de la planète assez importante.
Soit, sans océan, cette déformation est plus modeste. C'est le tableau en haut à gauche (droite ?).
On attend, sans trop se tromper,
que la différence, pour Europe, est d'un facteur de presque 100.
On va déplacer de 20cm, difficiles à mesurer. On va déplacer de 30m au cours d'un tour de Jupiter.
C'est plus dur, pour Ganymède et Callisto, de mesurer 4m d'amplitude de déformation de la lune.
C'est faisable sur un objectif à 2028, ce n'est pas le plus difficile.
Voilà la preuve, en plus du champ magnétique induit qu'on va mesurer plus précisément.
La preuve de l'existence de ces océans liquides ou de leur non existence,
je ne peux pas être catégorique,
viendra par une mission orbitale autour de ces lunes.
En mesurant le champ magnétique induit et cette déformation des surfaces.
Pour Saturne, on y retournera sans doute,
pour étudier Titan en détails.
Il y a deux ans, un projet de l'agence spatiale européenne,
appelé TSSM Tandem, Titan Saturn System Mission,
était ambitieux, avec un orbiteur autour de Titan.
Ainsi qu'un système de dépôt de ballon qui naviguerait dans l'atmosphère.
C'est simple car l’atmosphère  de Titan est dense à 1 bar en surface, comme la Terre.
Il pourrait faire de l'imagerie haute résolution, des mesures in situ de composition atmosphérique etc...
Je parle du ballon car c'est une initiative financée par l'agence spatiale française.
Ce projet existe toujours. Même si l'autre projet est passé devant, on ne le met pas à la poubelle.
Les études de faisabilité et de projet ballon continuent sur Titan et Vénus aussi,
entre le CNES et l'agence américaine, pour 2030 et au delà.
Le ballon a différentes formes mais il est sûr
qu'on verra dans les prochaines décennies un retour sur Titan,
avec une étude très approfondie de cette lune, pour les raisons évoquées.
Je vais arrêter là, avec des conclusions sur des projets ambitieux futurs.
Étant pessimiste, je ne pense pas que nous les verrons.
Le projet Gibbon, en bas à droite, envisagé par les américains,
est dans une configuration Star Trek car c'est un vaisseau spatial.
Son budget annoncé de 15 milliards de dollars a refroidi le Congrès américain.
On ne le verra pas avant très longtemps.
On n'en a pas forcément besoin. La politique est de faire
des missions moins ambitieuses mais plus répétitives.
Les gros projets qui peuvent voir le jour ne parlent pas d'envoyer quelque chose à la surface.
Comme on fait sur Mars où on a des robots en permanence.
Pour étudier l’habitabilité et la vie fossile etc, il faut des robots in situ.
Sur les lunes, les 4 mégarad, comme à la surface d'Europe, sont un problème.
Vous grillez l'électronique donc poser un robot conséquent sur Europe
qui va survivre deux heures, est très ambitieux et risqué.
Aucune agence n'est prête à le faire exceptés les Russes.
Ce projet de Roscosmos verra peut-être le jour.
Il est possible qu'ils décident de renvoyer un engin sur Europa,
avec une étude in situ.
Pour l'instant, ce n'est pas considéré comme concret au cours des deux décennies à venir.
Et j'arrêterai là, merci.
[applaudissements]
[applaudissements et bruits de pas]
Prenez le temps de boire un peu après avoir parlé d'eau pendant une heure.
Merci pour ces informations au pluriel.
Il va nous falloir du temps pour digérer tout ce que vous avez partagé.
Suite à cette conférence riche en enseignements,
en astronomie, on atteint vite des strates très pointues,
je suis sûre qu'il y a des questions dans la salle.
[ On vient vers vous après le monsieur]
[- Bonsoir, merci pour la conférence.]
[J'ai 3 questions. J'ai entendu parler d'une calotte de glace sur Mars,]
[appelée oréglite. Certains pensent qu'il peut y avoir des océans profonds]
[Comme vous avez dit qu'il n'y en avait pas, qu'en est il ?
[Une question sur Pluton : y a t il quelque chose sur Pluton ?]
[Une question plus technique : comment expliquer la courbe spéciale de l'eau et du mercure en thermodynamique ?]
- 3 questions en une [rires], on les prend dans l'ordre.
- Pour Mars, deux choses distinctes, il y a des calottes polaires qui n'ont rien à voir avec le régolite.
Ce sont bien des calottes de glaces d'eau et dioxyde de carbone,
avec des migrations saisonnières.
Ces calottes glaciaires aux pôles ont été étudiées par imagerie radar :
on a pu faire des profils en profondeur, on est remonté jusqu'à l'interface avec les silicates.
Totalement glace.  L'environnement n'autorise pas l'eau liquide.
Le régolite, c'est autre autre chose. C'est le même que le régolite sibérien.
C'est cette capacité du sol poreux à emmagasiner de l'eau dans les pores.
Dans le contexte martien très froid, où la pression est faible,
cette eau est sous forme de glace. Peut-être de clathrate,
cette structure en cage que l'eau peut prendre en gelant, qui va piéger des gaz.
C'est devenu célèbre dans le golfe du Mexique, ça a fait exploser le fameux bouchon.
Des hydrocarbures et de l'eau sous pression, ça fait des clathrates. C'est une glace particulière.
Dans le régolite martien, c'est toujours envisagé.
C'est un milieu poreux, il y a sans doute de l'eau, très peu.
Combien de très peu ? ça peut être plusieurs hectolitres
[sourire] Avec cette notion de pression, si on descend en profondeur et qu'il y a de l'eau dans les pores,
cette eau pourrait faire des aquifères en profondeur.
Il faudrait descendre très profond, qu'il y ait beaucoup d'eau.
Je ne dis pas que ce n'est pas le cas car des exemples de structures géologiques à la surface de Mars
qui font penser que c'est lié à une coulée, analogue à une coulée de boue,
qui s'expliquerait par la liquéfaction d'une partie de l'eau du régolite.
C'est vrai mais personne à ce jour n'avance l'idée d'un gros réservoir liquide en profondeur dans ces aquifères.
Question n°2 qui concerne Pluton.
Je n'en ai as parlé car c'est une planète et non une lune.
Ensuite car on n'a pas le même degré de connaissances. C'est tellement loin.
On sait de quoi est fait Pluton, je peux vous faire un schéma de structure interne de Pluton.
On ne s'aventure pas à dire s'il y a, ou non, des couches liquides en profondeur
car on n'a pas les évidences que je vous ai montrées dans le contexte de Jupiter et Saturne.
Pluton est bien connue, sa composition de surface, son atmosphère, Charon est dans le même genre.
On connaît la proportion de glace. Dans le système externe, la notion de 50% reste valide.
On a peu d'observations, attendons la mission "New Horizons", partie il y a 3 ans,
qui arrive vers 2016 pour faire un survol de Pluton.
Cette mission devrait nous en dire plus sur l'intérieur de Pluton.
Quant à la dernière question, on fait un cours de thermodynamique après la séance, si vous voulez, mais c'est bien plus compliqué.
- Julie, juste à côté, en fait, une demoiselle.
- Bonjour.
- Après, on ira vers vous.
- L'homme voudrait plutôt coloniser Mars ou une lune de Saturne ou Jupiter, du type Europe, Titan?
Ce qui est apte à être colonisé en premier ?
- J'espère que l'Homme n'aspire pas à coloniser. Je te pardonne. Nous aspirons à explorer.
L'exploration a deux volets : robotique et humain.
Aujourd'hui, l'exploration humaine se limite à la Lune.
Je ne crois pas... Je vais le dire différemment... Je peux montrer un transparent ?
[- Bien sûr.]
- Je le garde pour la fin car la question vient toujours.
[Il est en anglais, excusez moi.]
[Voilà l'état des lieux de l'exploration spatiale.]
C'est un transparent de l'agence spatiale européenne qui nous donne
les différentes étapes de l'exploration humaine du système solaire.
Pour explorer le système solaire, il faut d'abord envoyer des casseroles vides.
On l'a fait il y a 50 as, Spoutnik est une casserole vide.
C'est la première colonne du transparent.
Dans une casserole vide, on va mettre des instruments scientifiques
pour apprendre quelque chose sur l'environnement exploré.
C'est l'étape n°2 : être capable de mettre des instruments.
Une fois qu'on connaît l'environnement souvent très hostile,
on comprend comment se protéger contre l'hostilité de cet environnement.
On voit des bouteilles, plein de trucs, résister à la pression... Plein de problèmes comme ça.
[Quand on sait se protéger, apprenons à y vivre,]
puisqu'on peut y aller, on sait comment se protéger.
Une fois qu'on sait y vivre, la question est d'y installer une colonie,
une vie humaine durable à la surface d'une planète.
Une fois qu'on sait faire ça, on commence à exploiter.
On est dans un phase d'exploitation de cet environnement.
En bas, dans le cas de la Terre, on a l'exemple
que ces deux processus là ne vont pas toujours dans le même sens.
Une exploitation trop intense permet de se reposer cette question là.
Mais dans l'exploration, on n'en est pas là.
Pour la Terre, tout est bleu, on sait tout faire.
Au dessus, l'orbite basse, la station internationale.
On sait y envoyer des casseroles vides avec des instruments.
On sait se protéger contre l'environnement hostile.
On envoie des astronautes russes pendant presque un an.
Ils ne sont pas en très bon état quand ils redescendent mais on sait faire.
Après, on commence à explorer cette notion de travail dans l'espace.
Quant à maintenir une vie durable, on n'en est pas là, c'est très difficile voire infaisable.
Là, je suis juste en orbite basse. Sur la Lune, ça se complique.
On sait y envoyer des casseroles vides avec des instruments.
C'est cher et pas toujours facile.
On ne sait pas encore bien se protéger contre l'environnement hostile.
La Lune est très hostile, en fait.
Pour Mars, l'ESA n'envoie pas encore de casserole vide. L'agence américaine sait le faire
et va même envoyer une voiture.
La nouvelle mission martienne, Mars Sample (Science ?) Laboratory, qui décolle en novembre 2011,
est une voiture avec 200km d'autonomie à la surface de Mars.
Eux sont dans le gris, limite bleu sur certains domaines.
Hors de question de parler d'exploration humaine sur Mars.
Il y a dix ans, on commençait à en parler pour 2030.
[Aujourd'hui, dans les agences française, européenne ou internationale,]
plus personne ne parle d'exploration humaine de Mars.
On ne sait pas comment ramener un échantillon, avant 2030.
Envoyer un homme est hors de question.
Au delà de Mars, c'est "beyond", la réponse à ta question est là.
La Lune est une phase obligatoire de l’exploration,
non pour l'intérêt scientifique, ou parce qu'on va s'y développer plus tard,
mais c'est un jalon nécessaire si on veut aller au delà,
dans notre compétence technologique et notre capacité à nous adapter à l'hostilité de l'espace.
Une fois que ce sera fait, on envisagera Mars.
Ce n'est pas plus intéressant, mais c'est plus accessible.
Là on est dans la science fiction totale.
[-Merci. J'ai entendu dire que le Soleil] se réchauffait de 5% tous les milliards d'années
et que ça permettrait de mettre Mars du côté vivable plus tard.
[- C'est faux] mais pas totalement.
Le Soleil évolue dans le temps.
Parce qu'il a évolué il y a 3 milliards d'années,
Mars a perdu son habitabilité.
C'est une des raisons.
Il y a eu des tempêtes solaires à différentes époques
qui expliquent pourquoi Mars a perdu cette propriété.
Oui le Soleil évolue continuellement, certainement pas de 5%.
Tu as du mal à faire un système plus stable qu'une étoile.
Elle est là depuis 4.5 milliards d'années et elle est encore là pour 4.5 MA.
Elle évolue globalement, il est vrai que la zone habitable va migrer.
Et tu as raison, elle va migrer vers Mars, mais
je ne crois pas qu'on verra Mars habitable, ça va trop lentement.
[- Merci]
- Mademoiselle au milieu, voilà.
Après, Julie, une question, en haut, du monsieur sous le projecteur.
[- Bonsoir. J'ai lu sur internet que, dans 2 jours, il y] aurait une conférence sur une éventuelle vie extraterrestre.
Avez vous des précisions sur le sujet de cette conférence ?
Et est ce lié à ce que vous nous avez présenté ?
- Absolument pas. Si vous me précisez le lieu et les personnes, je pourrais peut-être,
pour l'instant je ne sais pas de quoi vous parlez.
[- Je n'ai pas cherché plus [sourire]] je suis désolée.
[- Je peux répondre différemment,]
dans la communauté scientifique et le grand public,
il existe des conférences sur l'exobiologie donc la biologie extraterrestre
qui n'est pas forcément liée à la vie extraterrestre.
Il y a une forte activité de la communauté scientifique en relation avec la vie extraterrestre.
Bizarrement, pas comme on le pense.
Je vais le dire.
Un très gros débat, dans les missions spatiales, est la protection planétaire.
Contrairement à ce qu'on croit, ce n'est pas par peur de contaminer des espèces extraterrestres et
parce qu'on pourrait leur faire du mal.
C'est parce qu'on fait très attention, il y a des normes très strictes, sur toute mission,
pour se prémunir d'une éventuelle contamination terrestre sur un environnement extraterrestre.
La grosse activité d'exobiologie,
pas en recherche mais en mission spatiale,
ce n'est pas d'aller chercher des petites bêtes,
c'est de respecter ces normes d'exploration de nouveaux mondes.
Il y a des catégories très claires sur des mondes habitables ou non.
C'est à dire qu'on peut envoyer une casserole avec microbes et bactéries vers Mercure, ça n'a pas d'importance.
Si on va sur Europe, on fait attention au nombre de spores par millimètre cube qu'on met dans notre engin spatial.
Il y a beaucoup de conférences et de travaux sur le sujet.
Celle dont vous me parlez, je ne sais pas du tout [sourire]
[- Bonsoir. Merci pour la conférence, vos transparents sont très bien faits.]
[Je voulais poser deux ou trois questions.]
[On parle d'eau depuis le début, où s'est elle synthétisée ?]
[Dans quels types de corps ? A quel moment on a pu]
avoir de l'eau ? Dans les nébuleuses ou autres corps ?
Ma deuxième question concerne le champ magnétique de la Terre.
Il parait qu'il s'inverse doucement en ce moment,
pourrait on perdre de l'eau à cause du vent solaire ? Merci.
- Alors... La réponse à la deuxième, d'abord, je l'ai bien en tête.
Je ne suis pas certain qu'on puisse affirmer que le champ magnétique s'inverse.
Il est en train de diminuer fortement d'intensité.
En général, dans les épisodes géologiques du passé,
cela s'accompagne des inversions du champ.
Les inversions du champ magnétique sont communes pour un géologue.
Quand on regarde les planchers océaniques de la Terre, formés dans les dorsales médio-océaniques,
au niveau des grandes lignes de montagnes qui traversent nos océans,
le roches en fusion qui arrivent en surface ont du fer et de la magnétite.
Ce fer enregistre le champ magnétique quand il se solidifie.
Quand on regarde le magnétisme des roches le long des planchers océaniques,
c'est une des preuves de la tectonique des plaques et de la dérive des continents,
on voit que les champs magnétiques s'inversent de façon standard, dans l'histoire de la Terre.
Je ne peux pas l'affirmer, mais si le champ magnétique s'inverse, l'histoire géologique nous prouve que ça ne fait pas disparaitre l'eau.
On est certain que l'eau est là depuis longtemps.
Elle a survécu sans problème à ces inversions de champ magnétique.
Je vais avoir l'air bête, mais je ne me rappelle plus la question.
- Cela portait [sur la façon dont avait été synthétisée l'eau.]
- Ah ! l'eau ! - Voilà.
- Vaste débat. Je ne suis pas sûr d'avoir la réponse.
Pour les gens comme moi, qui ne travaillent pas sur les origines du système solaire,
qui est un monde particulier,
on considère toujours que tous les éléments sont là, au départ.
On ne sait pas sous quelle forme.
J'ai parlé des clathrates et des hydrates, par exemple.
On ne sait pas comment se sont formées les lunes.
Avec des glaces d'eau pures d'un côté ?
Et à côté, les glaces d'ammoniaque, puis celle de CO2, puis celles de méthane etc ?
Ou se sont elles formées en étant déjà mélangées entre elles pour former des structures particulières ?
C'est la question qu'on se pose.
Au départ, les éléments sont dans les nébuleuses, vous l'avez abordé dans la question.
Quand on fait de la cosmo-chimie et de l'astronomie en général,
avec les imageries infra rouges, on détecte les molécules d'eau dans les nébuleuses.
Donc elle est là, oui.
Mais sous quelle forme ? On n'est pas sûrs de nous.
[- J'ai une question.]
- On ne vous voit pas.
[- Cela concerne l'atmosphère des lunes. La composition des atmosphères est elle similaire sur la plupart des lunes ?]
[ Cela peut il nous permettre de savoir] ce qui se passe sous les glaces ?
Peut on avoir des connaissances de composition à partir de l'atmosphère ?
- C'est un débat très complexe. Pour Titan, la réponse est oui.
C'est comme la Terre, 1 bar en surface. Une atmosphère dense qui n'est pas arrivée de l'extérieur.
C'est très lié à l'activité interne et la composition globale de la planète.
Mais posez vous la question sur Terre :
l'atmosphère vous renseigne-t-elle sur la composition interne ? Je vous mets au défi de me le prouver.
[On est dans le même contexte mais il existe une relation évidente]
entre la composition de l'atmosphère terrestre et sa composition globale, quand  on a le mode d'emploi.
Pour Titan, on est dans la même logique. Pour les autres lunes, c'est très compliqué
car les atmosphères sont très ténues.
On parle de quelques particules par mètre cube. La pression est à un millionième de bar,
on ne risque pas de la respirer.
Dans le cas de Jupiter, c'est complexe en raison du tore de Io.
La surface  de Io est fouettée par la magnétosphère Jovienne en permanence
car la magnétosphère de Jupiter tourne plus vite que la lune autour de Jupiter.
En permanence, la lune est fouettée.
Ça créé un tore de particules, observé par Voyager et Galiléo.
On a vu un truc bizarre sur une des images, comme un pont [entre une des lunes et Jupiter. C'est ce tore de Io.]
[Ces particules] ne s'arrêtent pas là, elles vont fouetter les autres lunes.
Dans mes transparents, beaucoup des tâches rouges sur Europe
sont, pour la moitié d'entre elles, du soufre qui vient de Io.
On le retrouve aussi dans l'exosphère ou atmosphère.
La nature endogène, l’origine des particules de ces atmosphères
n'est pas nécessairement liée à la composition des lunes elles-mêmes.
On est loin d'en être persuadés et c'est un problème pour nous.
[- Bonsoir. Dans les derniers transparents on voit les futures missions vers les lunes,
envisage -t-on d'aller faire des forages, comme on le voit sur une image ?
Dans les missions à l'étude, financées dans les vingt ans qui viennent, non, on ne l'envisage pas.
Dans les projets phase 0, les études initiales de faisabilité,
est ce farfelu ou peut-on l'envisager ? Oui.
Il y a des projets très sérieux qui sont étudiés.
Pas de forage, oublions cette notion.
Bruce Willis dans Armaggedon... C'est pas demain la veille qu'on fera des forages sur une planète [extraterrestre,]
[ ou sur une lune]
Par contre, en robotique, oui.
Sur les glaces, il y a un projet, Cryobot.
L'idée est de mettre une pile nucléaire sur un gros suppositoire.
Comme ça va chauffer, ça descendra à travers les glaces
et explorer les profondeurs des glaces.
Sans intervention humaine.
Un projet existe déjà, pas en radioactif. Je dis peut-être une bêtise.
Il y a une étude de faisabilité pour l'Antarctique. Ça marche bien.
On n'étudie pas ces projets dans une phase plus avancée,
pour les missions à partir.
[- Deuxième question,] au sujet du financement refusé par le congrès américain.
Est il possible d'envisager des financements autre qu'américains?
- Je parlais de ça pour la mission qui coûte plus de 15 milliards $.
[- La mission d'atterrissage sur Titan.]
- Oui. Les missions sont financées par les agences spatiales, la NASA ou l'agence européenne,
ou la JAXA chez les Japonais, Roskosmos chez les Russes etc.
Il n'y a pas que la NASA. Les Japonais sont allées sur la Lune récemment.
[- Vous l'avez déjà fâché, si vous] remettez une couche, ça ne va pas aller. -[sourire]
- Les Chinois ont leur agence et leur financement.
Sur des missions comme ça, il est nécessaire de joindre les budgets.
On ne sait plus où on en est, dans les budgets. Je ne parle pas du spatial mais globalement [sourire].
Si une nation a les moyens, elle peut se payer une mission vers Jupiter. C'est pas de coûts astronomiques.
Dans les politiques spatiales actuelles, les budgets ne sont pas considérables, même aux États-Unis.
Pour des missions de cette envergure, il faut joindre les moyens techniques et financiers.
[- OK. Dernière question plus scientifique,]
Dans le transparent sur l'habitabilité, sur Europe, vous parlez de l'évolution en pression et température.
Qu'est ce qui permet de postuler que la température augmente ? Qu'on atteint 0° ?
[- La thermodynamique, mon diagramme] de phase.
Le domaine de l'eau liquide est restreint à un domaine très modeste de températures.
[- Même quand la pression augmente ?]
- Oui, parce qu'il y a le point critique dont j'ai parlé.
Pardon le point triple. Mais il y a aussi [le point critique, qui est ailleurs.]
[C'est un turc tordu que les étudiants de physique adorent : ]
[Quand on passe au delà] de la limite entre liquide et vapeur,
la courbe n'est pas infinie, elle s'arrête au point critique.
Au delà, on est dans en fluide mais plus en liquide. Exit la notion de liquide.
Simplement, si on envisage les océans liquides,
on admet qu'il faut une température modérée aux alentours de 0°.
A -20°, il n'y a plus d'eau liquide, quelque soit la pression.
Et a 200°, il n'y a plus d'eau liquide non plus.
A 200°, vous ne pouvez pas expliquer la surface d'Europe.
En dessous de -20, vous n'expliquez pas ce que j'ai montré sur les surfaces.
Donc vous êtes entre -20 et 0, difficile de faire autrement.
[- OK, merci.]
- On prend encore une ou deux questions ? Trois questions.
[- Merci beaucoup pour votre conférence intéressante.]
Il faudra attendre 2028 pour avoir des preuves d'eau liquide sur les lunes du système solaire,
par un survol de longue durée autour de ces lunes.
Envisage-t-on, dans les 10 ans à venir,
d'avoir de très forts indices sinon des preuves d'eau liquide
dans des systèmes solaires, ailleurs dans la galaxie ?
Puisqu'on ne pourra pas survoler ces endroits avant plusieurs siècles,
pourra-t-on avoir des informations grâce à des nouveaux satellites ou télescopes ?
- J'ai une conférence toute prête sur les super Terre et les planètes océans sur autres systèmes stellaires.
Oui, le débat est réel.
En deux mots,
cette question tourne autour des exoplanètes qu’on découvre, des dizaines par mois,
autour d'autres étoiles, à quelques années-lumière de chez nous.
Très loin voire dans le bulbe galactique.
On a découvert plus de 500 planètes, dans 5 ans, on en aura plus de 3000, ça va très vite.
Elles sont inatteignables aujourd'hui.
Pourrons nous démontrer qu'il y a de l'eau liquide ?
Je pense que nous sommes dans la même logique que lorsque les Hommes
se demandaient s'il y avait de l'eau sur les lunes de Jupiter et Saturne, avant l'exploration spatiale.
Avec nos moyens au sol, on observait les lunes.
L'albédo nous permettait déjà de dire qu'il y avait de l'eau. De la glace, c'est certain.
Démontrer, par ces observations, la présence d'eau liquide ? Non.
Ces sont des modèles et des vues de l'esprit. On pouvait dire qu'il y en avait ou dire qu'il n'y en avait pas. Aucune preuve.
Les exoplanètes sont inatteignables. Vous dites plusieurs siècles. Peut-être.
Il faut remettre à plat toute notre physique et notre compréhension de l'univers,
admettons qu'elles ne soient pas atteignables par l'exploration humaine.
On peut les étudier en détails. Les projets actuels vont au delà de ce qu'on sait faire.
Aujourd'hui, pour une exoplanète, on sait donner sa masse et son rayon.
Donc on peut dire si c'est plutôt une planète rocheuse ou une planète océan, riche en eau, comme nos lunes,
ou encore une planète gazeuse. On en est là.
Sur les 500 dont j'ai parlé, on peut en voir 3 réellement.
On commence aussi à faire de la spectroscopie : on peut pointer une télescope infrarouge
le spectre d'une planète, ce minuscule pixel de rien du tout qui est dans l'espace.
Et dire, tac ! J'ai de l'eau.
Giovanna Tinetti, en 2006, dans un papier de Nature, a démontré la première trace d'eau dans une atmosphère d'exoplanète, oui.
Dans les décennies à venir, je ne m'aventure pas trop vous dire
qu'on va trouver des super Terre, des planètes océans,
i.e. on va trouver des planètes avec masse et rayon compatible, avec
tant de pourcentage de glace par rapport à la roche etc.
Preuves indiscutables d'eau en surface. Oui
De là à caractériser l'intérieur, l'habitabilité,
cette notion d'eau liquide etc, personnellement, je n'y crois pas.
Je peux me tromper.
[- Bonsoir, vous avez commencé à répondre à ma question, en parlant des financements.]
Aidez moi à comprendre comment on peut faire un plan pour les banques de 700 milliards.
Pourquoi financer une mission à 15 milliards est compliqué ?
- Je ne vous aiderai pas à comprendre puisque je ne le comprends pas moi même.
Si, je comprends très bien, en fait, c'est un sujet abordé au dîner.
On compare toujours à la mission Pathfinder : le premier robot à roulettes envoyé sur Mars,
qui a coûté, a quelques dizaines de milliers de $ près, le budget de Waterworld, de Kévin Costner.
[- J'ai dit qu'il avait couté ]cher.
- Il avait coûté cher à l'époque.
Le coût consolidé de la mission spatiale de la NASA
est le total du coût de l'étude de faisabilité au traitement des données,
des salaires des gens impliqués dans le projet, des instruments,
de la technologie embarquée. Voilà le coût de la mission.
Pourquoi un tel patacaisse ? Pourquoi les missions sont très chères ?
Pour les missions larges de l'ESA, on parle d'un milliard.
3 milliards €, en coût consolidé.
Sur 20 ou 30 ans, sans retour sur investissement direct.
En fait, il y en a beaucoup. Les satellites de positionnement,
les microtechnologies, qu'on utilise tous les jours,
c'est en partie grâce à l'exploration spatiale.
Elle sert à financer les études de pointe. C'est un challenge à tous niveaux.
Donc il y aura un retour sur investissement, inconnu à l'avance.
Justifier une mission est un choix politique, bien sûr.
Les états membres de l'Europe ont une contribution obligatoire aux missions de l'ESA.
Elle peut changer.
En regardant en détail, ça ne coûte pas si cher.
La mission elle même n'est que la partie immergée de l'iceberg
et elle est difficile à justifier car elle n'a pas de retour sur investissement comme Water World.
Quant aux banques, c'est un autre débat qui ne nous concerne pas ce soir.
[- Bonsoir, merci pour la qualité de votre prestation.]
[J'aimerais avoir une précision quant à la nuance que vous apportez aux notions de viabilité et d’habitabilité]
[Quelle est, du côté humain,] l'importance de cette différence ? Merci
- La première partie de la question, c'est...
-La différence entre viabilité et habitabilité.
- Celle là, c'est simple : on a un problème de jargon,
on est très conditionnés par l'anglo-saxon, la langue américaine,
dans le domaine scientifique, on doit parler l'anglais couramment.
Quand ils parlent d'habitabilité, habitability,
cela est traduit par viabilité, en Europe.
On a inventé le mot habitabilité, qui ne veut rien dire pour nous,
pour faire un copier-coller du système américain.
Mais cela a généré une confusion dans les esprits
car les médias ont parlé de monde habitable. Moi le premier, ça m'arrive.
J'espère ne pas m'être trompé ce soir. Toujours, j'essaie de faire la part des choses
car on se rend compte que la notion de monde habitable est proche, pour la majorité des gens,
de la notion de monde habité : si c'est habitable alors la vie est possible. Pas du tout.
L'habitabilité est la réunion des 4 conditions dont j'ai parlé.
Quand on a de l'eau liquide , une chimie, complexe, des sources énergétiques et du temps,
nous ne franchissions jamais le pas de dire qu'on a vraiment quelque chose.
Tant que nous n'aurons pas démontré qu'il y a eu des bactéries sur Mars
ou observé des micro organismes à la surface de Ganymède, Europe ou ailleurs,
nous ne parlerons pas de monde habité ou viable.
L'habitabilité, ça reste physique et aussi temporel.
La viabilité est la capacité de faire vivre quelque chose. Si c'est viable, on y vit très bien.
Ben non, dans les contextes spatiaux, on a du mal à survivre, y vivre est plus complexe.
Par contre, l'habitabilité, on l'a connue sur Mars dans le passé.
Peut-être aujourd’hui sur Europe, Ganymède.
C'est difficile, on n'a pas encore trouvé le bon mot pour parler de ça.
Ça répond en partie à la deuxième, la dimension humaine des choses est complexe à aborder.
Pour nous... Pour le dire clairement, je me force à ne pas m'y intéresser.
Mon rôle dans la préparation de la future mission vers Jupiter n'est pas de parler de la vie qu'on va essayer de trouver.
C'est la meilleure façon de se faire descendre par la communauté des astronomes et de perdre la compétition.
Pourquoi ? Car nous sommes incapables de détecter le moindre micro organisme à la surface d'une lune,
ni au fonds d'un océan à 100 km de profondeur. C'est totalement irréalisable.
Malheureusement, des gens vendent les missions spatiales en disant : on va détecter la vie [raclement de gorge]
Ça s'est passé sur les programmes martiens, la communauté réfléchit sérieusement, en dehors des coûts.
Il faut arrêter de vendre les missions martiennes en disant qu'on va détecter la vie martienne.
Ce n'est pas l'objectif humain prioritaire d'aller détecter la vie fossile,
je parle personnellement, tout le monde n'est pas d'accord.
[Ma vision de la dimension humaine est que ça ne passe pas par la démonstration de la vie extraterrestre.
C'est sûr, ça change complètement la donne, mais on n'est pas encore capable de le faire, à mon avis.
[-Il y a un projet comme quoi Mars pourrait être habitable, avec des efforts, pendant 1500 à 2000 ans.]
Est il possible de rendre Mars habitable ?
- Je ne sais pas d'où vous tenez le nombre de 1500 ans. Est ce possible ?
Scientifiquement et techniquement... Enfin, théoriquement, oui.
Je vous envoie [vers un livre "Mars la rouge", suivi par "Mars la bleue" et "Mars la verte",]
[1500 pages au total.]
[- Ça vient de là, les 1500 ? C'est de l'humour.]
-Non. [rires] Peut-être.
Qui illustre bien cette capacité qu'on aurait de terraformer Mars.
C'est théoriquement faisable. Pratiquement, je vous renvoie au dernier transparent :
on a du mal à envoyer des casseroles.
C'est pas demain la veille qu'on remettra une atmosphère dense et respirable sur Mars.
Théoriquement, pourquoi pas. Pratiquement, c'est de la science fiction.
[- D'accord].
[- C'est de la science fiction mais] il y a toujours des questions autour de la vie sur Mars.
- Et [pour cause, nos observations montrent qu'on peut se poser la question à juste titre.]
La vie dont on parle, c'est les micro-organismes. Ils étaient là avant nous, ils seront là après nous.
Dans le contexte martien, nous n'avons pas dépassé cette dimension là.
Terraformer Mars est une autre paire de manches.
Une planète viable n'a pas besoin des conditions de la Terre aujourd'hui,
avec son atmosphère, sa pression et sa densité.
La rendre habitable pour un homme est différent de la rendre viable pour un micro organisme.
Ce sont bien deux choses distinctes.
Encore une fois, terraformer Mars est de la science fiction.
[- Une dernière question avant de se quitter.]
- Une dernière ?
[- Je croyais que Pluton avait été déclassée en tant que planète ?]
[- Vous avez raison, Pluton n'est] plus une planète. Elle fait partie de la vaste famille des planètes naines, on n'a pas fini d'en découvrir.
Ce n'est pas grave pour Pluton et pour les planétologues non plus.
- Voilà, on termine sur une question posée et une réponse positive de votre part.
Je vous invite à vous replonger dans les ouvrages présentés en début de conférence.
Et aux 1500 pages de "Mars la rouge", "Mars la bleue" et "Mars la verte".
Vous retrouverez Maëtte Chantrel la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle conférence :
la physique buissonnière, du nom de l'ouvrage de J-M Courty, qui est physicien.
Merci à Jérôme et Fabien, nos régisseurs.
Merci au créa de Rennes 2 qui filmait cette conférence.
Merci à vous, bon retour à Nantes et bonne nuit.
[applaudissements]